The rife function, we had a question come in that I missed, sorry, you know who you are,
about the function of the rife, what does it do, you know, is it, if it's killing bacteria
things, is it a killing by old cells? Boy, we could have a couple hour discussion on the
different theories on how rife frequency works. There's multiple theories on how it works. I do
cover this in some of my videos that are on our website on rife theory, but just real clearly.
Is it damaging by old cells if I'm running a program? I do not believe there's any damage to your
normal cells. If I'm running the liver frequency cell program and it's running through normal
liver frequencies, it's helping bring residents to my liver cells and it's going to help my liver
cells function better. Rife believed that running a frequency of a cancer and his whole thing was
trying to tune in to that frequency of the cancer. If he could hit that cancer with its own frequency,
he would cause lysis of that cell. And that's with how he believed he had success with cancer patients
that there was cell lysis. Now, I do believe that that may occur, but I don't believe that that
usually occurs. If you do hit a cancer frequency with its own, cancer cell with its own frequency,
remember, a cancer cell is your human body cell. So if you have breast cancer, it is a breast cell
that is in a rapid replication phase. What are the beliefs of rife? And I do believe that this does
take place many times is that when you hit a breast cancer cell with its own frequency,
a breast frequency, a breast cell frequency, you bring back normal residents to the cell and the
cell stops rapidly replicating. That's why you don't always get shrinkage of the tumor.
So remember, what a cancer is. Cancer is cells that are in a rapid replication phase. Well,
therefore, over time, there's a lot more cells. That's what a tumor is. So a tumor is cells that
are replicated. Therefore, they're getting more of them and they're getting larger. And then with
cancer, they're not going through normal apoptosis. So you're getting a mass that's getting bigger
and bigger and bigger. And I've told you a hundred times that our goal is not to make the mass go away.
That would be wonderful. We just wanted to stop growing because if it stops getting bigger,
then we know it's not replicating. So if we can stop its replication, this rapid replication,
it stops, quote unquote, being cancer. So it fell off the definition of cancer since the
definition of cancer is rapidly replicating cells. So if we can get it to stop replicating,
then we win. So that's the goal of this altogether. So one of the theories of
rife is that if you hit a cancer cell with its own frequency, liver cancer, breast cancer,
and you can bring residents back to that cell and it starts acting like a normal breast cell or
liver cell again, it stops replicating. That doesn't mean the mass is going to disappear. So you have
to get it out of your head that this mass in my breast may never go away. And that's okay. We just
got to get it to stop growing. So that's part of the function of the rife with cancer. No, there's at
least two dozen other theories that all are viable and they probably are all applicable with how
frequency medicine works with cancer. So now nothing is going to work beyond God's desire to work
in your life. So we are dealing with that as well. So we have to deal with what the sovereignty of God
has planned for the days of my life with this but we're supposed to be doing our part.
So the rife is not a magic tool. It's not going to be a cure-all for everything all the time,
but it's going to be a great tool for us.